>> Laura: THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE IS IN FULL CYA
MODE THIS EVENING PUSHING BACK
AGAINST AN AVALANCHE OF
CRITICISM ABOUT QUESTIONS OF ITS
CONDUCT DURING THE STONEMAN
DOUGLAS SCHOOL SHOOTING.
THAT INCLUDES INFORMATION FIRST
REPORTED EXCLUSIVELY ON THE
ANGLE WHEN A WELL-PLACED SOURCE
TOLD US THAT DEPUTIES WERE TOLD
NOT TO ENTER THE SCHOOL DURING
THE SHOOTING AND LESS THEIR BODY
CAMERAS WERE ON.
I CHARGE NOW BEING DENIED.
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE IS ALSO
DENYING REPORTS THAT A CAPTAIN
TOLD DEPUTIES TO FORM A
PERIMETER AROUND THE SCENE
INSTEAD OF GOING INTO CONFRONT
THE SHOOTER.
IT SAYS THE PERIMETER WAS FORMED
AFTER THE SHOOTING HAD STOPPED.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION IS
JEFF BELL, PRESIDENT OF THE
SHERIFF DEPUTIES ASSOCIATION AND
FORMER L.A. POLICE DETECTIVE
MARK
MARK FUHRMAN.
DRAFT, LET'S START WITH YOU.
THEY WERE ISSUING TODAY AFTER
ALL THESE DAYS THAT THESE
REPORTS WERE OUT THERE A FLURRY
OF DENIALS.
LET ME READ TO YOU WHAT THE
BROWARD SHERIFF'S OFFICE SAID IN
ITS FACT-CHECK ON BODY CAMERAS.
ANY SUGGESTION THAT PARIS GOT
ISRAEL OR ANY OTHER DEPUTY FROM
BROWARD SHERIFF'S OFFICE ORDERED
BODY CAMERAS TO BE TURNED ON
PRIOR TO ENTERING THE SCHOOLS IS
FALSE.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
WE HAVE TWO WELL-PLACED SOURCES
TELL US THAT IN FACT IT WAS THE
CASE THAT THEY WERE TOLD NOT TO
ENTER UNLESS THEY HAD THEIR BODY
CAMERAS ON.
>> I THINK THIS JUST FURTHER
AFFIRMS THE UNION'S POSITION
THAT WE ARE CALLING FOR THE
BROWARD SHERIFF'S OFFICE TO BE
TOTALLY TRANSPARENT IN THIS
INVESTIGATION TO RELEASE THE
INFORMATION OUT THERE BECAUSE BY
RELEASING PARTS OF THIS
INFORMATION THAT THEY HAVE TODAY
JUST FURTHER CREATES MORE
SPECULATION THAT THERE IS SOME
HIDDEN TRUTH BACK THERE.
THERE MAY OR MAY NOT BE, BUT IT
SURE DOES GIVE THE APPEARANCE
THAT SOMETHING IS BEING HIDDEN
FROM THE PUBLIC.
>> Laura: MARK, THERE SEEMS TO
HAVE BEEN QUITE A LAG IN THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE RELEASING THESE
CLARIFICATIONS FACT CHECKS.
AN ENORMOUS PRESSURE SCOTT
ISRAEL TO RESIGN GIVEN THE
REPEATED VISITS TO THE
HOUSEHOLD, THE RED FLAGS, ONE
AFTER THE OTHER MIST.
THIS IDEA THAT THERE WAS A
PERIMETER SET UP.
THAT WAS ONLY SET UP AFTER THE
SHOOTING HAD CEASED.
FROM WHAT YOU ARE GATHERING AND
WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN, WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION TO THESE SERIES OF FACT
CHECKS RELEASED TODAY?
>> IF I WAS ASSUMING WITH HIS
CAPTAIN, THIS FEMALE CAPTAIN
ORDERED A PERIMETER TO BE SET UP
WHILE SHE WAS NOT AT THE SCENE,
THAT WOULD GO AGAINST EVERY
TACTICAL OPERATION THAT I'VE
EVER HEARD OF.
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE IN CHARGE
OF THAT SCENE WHERE THE DEPUTIES
THAT FIRST ARRIVED.
THEY WERE IN CHARGE OF THAT
TACTICAL SEEM TO MAKE THE CALLS
APPEAR TO HAVE ANYBODY MAKE ANY
KIND OF CALL ON THE RADIO IS
INCOMPETENCE AT THE VERY BEST,
AND PROBABLY GETS WORSE FROM
THERE.
IT SEEMS THAT THERE IS NOTHING
THAT THEY CAN ACCOUNT FOR
IMMEDIATELY.
IT TAKES THEM A WEEK, TEN DAYS
TO COME UP WITH AN EXCUSE.
THOSE DEPUTIES DIDN'T GO IN FOR
A REASON.
THOSE DEPUTIES ARE DEPUTIES,
THEY ARE COPS.
THERE IS A SITUATION THERE AND
THEY WANT TO WAIT FOR AN ORDER.
THEY CAPABLE AND TRAIN AND THEY
NEED TO GO IN AND CONFRONT THE
SHOOTER.
THAT WAS THEIR JOB.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU GO BACK AND
LOOK AT THIS HORRIFIC SITUATION,
HORRIFIC SHOOTING, WE ALL KNOW,
WE SUPPORT OUR POLICE.
WE LOVE OUR POLICE OFFICERS, WE
LOVE OUR FIRST RESPONDERS, BUT
WE ALSO CAN LEARN FROM WHAT
HAPPENED ON THAT DATE.
IF IT WANTS TO RUN TO GUN
CONTROL, I GET IT.
THAT'S WITH THE LEFT WILL DO AND
EVEN SOME REPUBLICANS.
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME BASIC FACTS
THAT ARE JUST FACTS THAT WE
WOULD CERTAINLY LEARN ABOUT IF
WE HAD THE POLICE TRANSMISSION
OVER THE RADIO RELEASED.
WE HAVE THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING
WHERE WE STILL HAVEN'T SEEN
VIDEOTAPES OF THE SHOOTER
CHECKING INTO THE HOTEL,
BRINGING ALL THE BAGS.
JUST LIKE IT NEVER HAPPEN.
WE NEVER SEE THE VIDEO.
WHY HAVEN'T WE SEEN MORE VIDEO
AND WHY HAVEN'T WE HEARD THE
AUDIO OF THE POLICE RESPONSE?
JEFF, I WOULD LIKE YOUR RESPONSE
AND THEN MARK VERY QUICKLY.
>> THAT'S THE MILLION-DOLLAR
QUESTION THAT NOBODY KNOWS THE
ANSWER TO AND THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE DEMANDING THE TRANSPARENCY
ON THIS.
IF WE DID SOMETHING WRONG, WE
DID SOMETHING WRONG.
LET'S LEARN FROM THIS AND MOVE
FORWARD.
THE ONLY WAY TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM IS TO ACTUALLY
BE HONEST AND TRUTHFUL FOR IT.
WE HAVE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
BETTER TRAINING IN THIS AGENCY.
I'VE SAID IT BEFORE,
$887 MILLION REVISED BUDGET LAST
YEAR AND THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE
AND WE DON'T EVEN HAVE OUR OWN
GUN RANGE.
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE IN THE
TRAINING WE DO HAVE, I HAVE TO
GIVE CREDIT TO THE SERGEANTS AND
DEPUTIES THAT HAVE LARGER
CLASSES WITH WHAT LITTLE THEY
HAVE TO WORK WITH.
IF WE ARE GOING TO GET SERIOUS
ABOUT PROBLEMS LIKE THIS AND
ADDRESSING THE NEXT PROBLEM THAT
COMES DOWN THE ROAD, WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT OURSELVES AND LEARN FROM
INSTANCES LIKE THIS AND MOVE
FORWARD.
>> Laura: MARK?
>> WE DON'T NEED TO WAIT FOR THE
VIDEOS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE HOW MANY 911
CALLS CAME OUT FROM THOSE
CHILDREN INSIDE THAT SCHOOL?
THERE WAS PROBABLY A THOUSAND,
2,000 SALVOS IN THAT SCHOOL.
HOW ABOUT RELEASING SOME OF THE
911 CALLS, BECAUSE THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN RELAYED TO THOSE
OFFICERS THAT WERE RESPONDING
EXACTLY WHAT WAS GOING DOWN.
NOBODY THOUGHT THERE WERE SHOTS
OUTSIDE.
LET'S ACTUALLY GET REAL HERE.
EVERYBODY KNEW WHAT WAS GOING
DOWN.